I mean I are so aware and appreciative
of the incredible people who work hand
in hand with actors to help us create
characters that embody the story
obviously some of us need a lot less
help than others oh this no this is four
hours in a chair plus prosthetics calf
implants the creativity of those who are
in makeup and hairstyling experts played
such an important part of so many films
in 2017
here are the year's nominees for
achievement in makeup and hairstyle
darkest hour Kazuhiro Tsuji
David malinovski and Lucie Civic
Victoria and Abdul Daniel Phillips and
Lou Shepherd
wonder Arjen Titan
and the Oscar goes to thinking to get
anything in darkest hour
[Applause]
this is the first
David Malan
you see Civic the third nomination and
first win
patent hero soo-ji
[Music]
well that the glasses firstly we would
like to give our heartfelt thanks to
Gary Oldman it was a real honor to be on
this incredible journey with you and we
will not be standing here today if it
wasn't for you and you a wonderful actor
a dedicated artist and a true friend we
thank you for that we would also like to
thank Giselle Schmidt Duggar shebanski
the entire team at focused futures Alex
Turner disables Tim liban Anthony
McCartan and the director Joe Wright the
cast and crew our family and friends for
the amazing support and my cats
finally thank you to the Academy and
this is a dream come true for all of us
thank you
[Applause]